first I want to acknowledge
representatives from other states and
voluntary Services who have provided
invaluable Support over the last 24
hours including the Irish Coast Guard
the Coast Guard rescue helicopter won't
monase Irish air course medivac 112
Northern Ireland ambulance hem service
Irish Community air ambulance Northern
Ireland Urban search and rescue miva
fire service
Donegal Mountain Rescue
Northern Ireland Ambulance Service heart
team
Donegal County Council civil defense
and most importantly the community
increased luck
yesterday Friday the 8th of October at
approximately 3 20 p.m an explosion
occurred at a building complex increased
love County Donegal
I can now confirm there are 10
fatalities as a result of that explosion
the Emergency Services continue a search
and Recovery operation at the site this
afternoon
but based on the information available
to on guardashia corner at this time it
is not expected that there will be any
further casualties located and there are
no outstanding reports of unaccounted
for persons
the 10 casualties are four men three
women
two teenagers a boy and a girl and a
younger girl
the thoughts of all the emergency
service Personnel who have attended the
scene over the last 24 hours
the local community increased luck and
the nation are today with the deceased
on their families
in respect for the disease I now ask for
a short silent pause in their memory
I will now Ask Gary Martin director of
emergency services at Dundee gold County
Council to provide a briefing on the
ongoing local Authority and fire service
response
good afternoon uh everyone
I want to confirm that Donegal County
Council fire service mobilized sex
Brigade areas yesterday afternoon to
Chrisler including 65 fire service
Personnel in addition to that we
deployed 20 Donegal County Council civil
defense Personnel a structural engineer
and to facilitate the funding off of the
area road service personnel
I want to acknowledge the assistance
from our colleagues in the Northern
Ireland fire and rescue service who
attended with specialist equipment and
search dogs
I also want to acknowledge the huge
input from the local community
who attended in huge numbers from
yesterday afternoon
increased law and who contributed so
much to our efforts there
our primary focus yesterday
was to lead on the search and recovery
of the injured and to stabilize what was
a substantially damaged building
including many displaced and broken
concrete slabs
over the course of last night
and following a detailed analysis of the
site
by our crews aided by search dogs and
cameras and listening equipment the
incident moved into a search and
Recovery phase
we will remain on site and an ongoing
search and check phase
to ensure that there are no remaining
casualties in the building
I would like to acknowledge the
cooperation of everyone involved as we
went about our work yesterday and today
and in particular our major emergency
management colleagues and the Primary
Response agencies of the guardi and the
HSE
finally and on behalf of the council
as members and staff
I want to pass on our sincere
condolences to the families and friends
of the victims of this terrible tragedy
thank you
thank you Gary
I'm not going to ask JJ McGowan Chief
ambulance officer for the western region
of the national Ambulance Service to
provide a briefing on the national
Ambulance Service response to this
instance
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the HSE and the national
Ambulance Service they wish to express
our deepest emphasis in relation to this
terrible tragically which has unfolded
increasedly yesterday to our staff
including those in the hospital and
Community Health words cannot describe
your efforts each and every one of you
have gone above and beyond in your
response
a special word of thanks also goes to
those who have provided medical
assistance to us these include but are
not limited to the Northern Ireland
Ambulance Service and their heart team
and their aeromedical services the Irish
Community air ambulance ground Crews the
the Coast Guard rescue 118 helicopter
and the Letterkenny University Hospital
forward surgical team a special word of
thanks also goes to Dr Jerry Lee and who
assisted on behalf of the Irish
Community air ambulance we will continue
our efforts to work with our colleagues
in the Garrity and the fire service
until all recovery efforts have
concluded yesterday we transported eight
patients from the scene one of whom was
critical and further transported to the
hospital in Dublin seven of the patients
transported at this time remain in a
stable condition the national Ambulance
Service allocated a total of eight
emergency ambulance yesterday and three
this morning we also
dispatched two Intermediate Care or
patient transport Vehicles four doctors
and four ambulance officers we currently
have two emergency ambulances two
ambulance officers and one doctor on the
scene
our thoughts remain with the bereaved
victims those injured fellow responders
the community and all those who have
contributed to the rescue efforts from
12 noon today counseling and further
Services have been put in place by the
HSE at Chrysler community Day Care
Center thank you
thank you JJ I'm not going to ask
superintendent David Kelly of Milford
Gardner station to provide a briefing on
garage response and what the next steps
in the investigation of this incident
will be
good afternoon if you want to say thank
you for coming here today
yesterday afternoon I went to a meeting
in falcara actually driving by the
location where this happened little did
I think I'll be standing before you here
today this is a tragedy for our
community because families left
Devastators
and I suppose I just want to start off
by offering on behalf of myself and my
colleagues that attended the scene
yesterday and indeed are continuing to
do so are very sincere condolences
you've heard from my colleagues from the
two other services
initially the fire service took the lead
in this operation and they still do
we assisted them from regarded
perspective in terms of attending the
scene securing the scene making it a
safe place for themselves to work and
their personnel and indeed they're here
to see ambulance personnel
you've heard from my colleagues as well
there was great assistance given
throughout if you like the the relevant
emergency services in this jurisdiction
we also received great help from our
colleagues in Northern Ireland that's
what it is to be in Donegal we look out
for each other
I just like to say as well uh forgive me
if I get a bit of motion because you're
dealing with the public you know
what I would say in terms of what we did
I outlined that we worked with the
other services at this point in time we
have to keep an open mind as a police
service and how we investigate this but
at this our information at this point in
time is pointing towards a tragic
accident that said being a guarder I
have to
take a holistic and overall viewpoint
but that's where we're going at the
moment we are working in consultation as
I say with the coroner
in that regard
we put family liaison officers in place
where the families after deceased
we're also working with the HSE in terms
of the local community as well in terms
of offering if you like psychological
safety to the families and the wider
community in that regard
I suppose in terms of my own colleagues
I know my colleagues here with the fire
service and the ambulance service we
have to think of the people from our own
service that did attend and again
they're not the necessary resources have
been put in place in that regard
uh
I just like if you guard a response as
you as you can imagine the call comes in
we're directed by our North Regional
Western uh control center which is based
in Galway resources were initially
deployed from the Milford Garda District
here assisted by members that were off
duty
I'm proud to say I didn't have to ask
for people to turn out for Duty they
came in we were assisted by members from
Letterkenny Bally Shannon
currently we're working with the garden
National Technical Bureau and they're
giving us assistance
with specialist units within Tony gold
I'm not going to name them uh suffice to
say any resource like my colleagues have
said that is required we are putting
them in place and we are using them and
I hope I've answered most of your
questions if not I'm sure Liam and my
colleagues can help afterwards thank you
for your time
we're looking into that we're looking at
that at the moment We are following
certain if you like investigative angles
but at this point in time for
operational Reasons I'm not going to go
into that please
Virgin Media
I can answer that but I just have my
colleague from thank you yeah we
transported eight patients sorry we
transported eight patients to hospital
yesterday one of which is in critical
condition and we further transported
that by air to a hospital in Dublin uh
yesterday evening to the burdens unit
um off the other seven at this time we
believed they remain in a stable
condition and have not life-threatened
an injuries
yeah that's correct yeah
we're not going into age groups
again unfortunate this time it's it's
not even 24 hours since it happened as
my colleague Superman Kelly said we have
family liaison officers dealing with
very very traumatized families at this
time so we're not going into any
personal details of the families or the
individuals involved just for the moment
thank you
my understanding is everybody involved
are local to the Northern Eagle or the
chrislok area yes
don't have that specific information at
this time
again the members from our technical
view are are attending site we are able
to carry out some investigations but at
the moment the priority Still Remains
the Searcher decide to ensure there is
absolutely no no other occasions but
we're quite satisfied that not at the
moment but that investigation by the
technical will go on over the next
number of days
but we'll put it over the next number of
days it will be taken the time will be
taken to sure that this is investigated
fully to determine any of the causes of
of what it's called this tragic accident
s
the younger child is a girl
yes
another question anybody else any other
questions
[Music]
at this point in time and Kelly has said
all the indications are that it is a
tragic accident however the
investigation will determine the exact
nature of the cause but at this moment
in time it would appear to be a tragic
accident
security sorry
again we have to determine the exact
cause of the accident before we can
start going down the down down the route
of identifying any particular problem so
at the moment and that will follow as we
identify more issues and relations and
discuss the accidents is there any
information as to how long before the
first emergency
my understanding emergency services are
on the same within less than 10 minutes
um unfortunately I wasn't there myself
and I don't think any of my three
colleagues are necessarily there to sell
but I know talking both to my own
colleagues on the garage corner and I
know JJ and Gary talking to their
colleagues it was a very very traumatic
scene that people came across it was a
very very confused scene as you can
imagine and there was a lot of debris
there was a lot of very very you know
traumatized people you know already at
the scene so our colleagues definitely
will all be provided with their own
counseling services by our own agencies
to try and deal with what was a very
very tragic circumstances that they
arrived at this time yesterday afternoon
this is probably one of the largest
civilian casualties in in recent times
and that any of our services have
probably dealt with
um and certainly certainly one of the
largest um civilian casualties in in in
this region
um or certainly over recent years or
decades
with the search and Recovery property is
still ongoing to be 100 sure that the
search site is clear but any person that
was reported to us as being unaccounted
for we can now account for but obviously
we just need to make sure that there is
nobody else out there that we're not
aware of so that search and Recovery
operation will continue for the next few
hours and then it will become a guardian
garage Gardener will then take the lead
and the investigation will take take its
course over the next few days obviously
post mortems will need to be carried out
on the bodies of all the deceased and
working with the coroner and the state
pathology service on that that would
take place over the next few days
my understanding is that if 10
fatalities where all fatalities at the
scene
all the bodies have been removed at the
stage my understanding has all been
removed the letter Kenny um university
hospital at this stage let me ask you
the response of the local community
superintendent the response to the local
community has been um overwhelming
um they were dealing in a situation in
their Village in their local people
their neighbors
um they turned out in great numbers and
gave great assistance to the emergency
services and it's it's remarkable and
admirable as to how they wrecked it
in that there will be a range eventually
for the State pathologist's office to
determine and obviously there are 10
postmortems to be done so we will work
closely with them um as to how how that
needs process needs to happen
he did before the state pathologist
office or in the coroner's office is
determined okay
I again we'll hopefully maybe trying
with some sort of a short update later
on on today but again again we just have
to wait and see how things planned out
over the next few hours okay thank you
very much everybody thank you thank you